welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who loved looking up to
captain america
and this video are breaking down
everything we know about the episode 5
falcon in the winter soldier cameo i'm
going to be discussing all the
information we have from reliable
sources
along with what i've been told so far
this is purely because i did a tweet
last week that discussed what i'd been
told
and as it blew up i thought i'd go into
more depth just discussing all the ins
and outs of it
now if you enjoy the video then please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel for
breakdowns like this each and every day
we're also giving away three free copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
so make sure you stick around until the
end of the video so you can find out how
to get your hands on one
now malcolm spellman the series creator
has been teasing out what's to come in
several interviews on the show
when discussing what to expect he stated
there are characters in our series who i
would love to see partnered with like
it's a very very grounded character
partnered with one of the big world
shakers like thor
or someone like that the personality is
so strong
it's the episode 5 character i'd love to
see that character with thor
so from that we know it's a very
grounded character and that they have a
strong personality
spellman also cleared up that it was not
t'challa aka chadwick boseman
after the appearance by io many thought
that the actor
would pop up in the series but it now
has been clarified through vanity fair
that this isn't the case
he did however lend his voice to
marvel's upcoming series what if
where he will be appearing as a
different take on starlord
a slash film basically gave us a lot of
clues and an almost
guess who level of things to take from
what's going to be happening
they said the character has not been
seen in the mcu
and this rules out zola in the red skull
both of which
have been theorized as appearing in the
series it also narrows down the list to
being characters that are not in any of
the pre-existing films
and therefore wipes about 300 names
completely off the list maybe more
now secondly they aren't likely to
appear in any upcoming film
and the cameo isn't setting up a movie
this rules out people from the black
widow film
some of which i'll be discussing later
in the video and pretty much means that
it's gonna be a standalone moment for
the show
lots of bad news for us speculating
there but they have said that they were
not created for this series
and that this character does exist in
the comics they reiterated that they're
also a well-known actor
and they have several awards under their
belts this was later confirmed by peter
scaretta
of the slash film podcast who said the
following there was this interview
with the showrunner of the show uh
spellman
with rotten tomatoes and he talked about
episode 5 which is the next episode
coming up so
this is a quote that's been going around
the internet so if you don't want to
hear it you know tune out now but
he's been saying this publicly he says
that there is a
big surprise character coming who he
considers to be
the episode 5 character
and he says and he also said i think
episode five will like make people cry
um he says it's a big episode in this
this season
he says that the character has a quote
strong personality
and you'd like to see this individual
side by side with thor in a future like
movie or show
who do you think that is fred i really
don't know it was i i
um i tried to think about this because
we talked about that this was you know
in this in the slack and i'm honestly
not
sure because like i couldn't really
think of anybody who was like
who would be a big deal that
yeah i don't know i really don't know
well i'll tell you i know but i'm not
i'm not going to reveal this because i
don't want to ruin the fun
for for anyone out there but i will say
that it's not a character that's from
the marvel movies it's a marvel a big
marvel character
and it is um it's a big
uh actor who
who hasn't been named in the series like
so like usually we get the casting and
stuff like that
so this is someone we didn't know was
going to be in this the the series and
is an award-winning actor actress
so so there you go so let the that rumor
milk go
until i'm sure we're going to find out
next week well no we are going to find
out next week because spelman said we're
going to find out next week
so um yeah now the fact they say actor
and bring up actress
makes me think that they might have said
that purely because the cameo will be a
woman
last year when filming was going on i
actually received an email from someone
that sent a picture
of the image by atlanta film at the
decal courthouse
they said that they had also seen an
image of a blonde woman with a cut over
her head
who had been snapped leaving the set he
said they didn't know who it was but
thought that that could be the cameo
and i didn't report on it at the time
because i do about 70 videos a week yeah
get off my back about it
now atlanta filming's original post said
that the show filmed there for two days
and when you see who is in the scene
then don't forget to message them when
your mind explodes
that was all the way back on the 28th of
february 2020
but i'll enter filming followed up on
the 2nd of april saying that as far as
he knew
she was still in it and because of this
comment i did link the two images
now i did post this on twitter that i'd
heard it was a blonde woman
and this post kind of blew up a bit on
reddit you should never assume anything
as it makes an ass out of you and me and
since then atlanta filming has come out
and said
just stop and also that it's not a woman
but i'm sure most
of you can see why i linked the email
with these pictures and tweets in
and thought it was legit because of it
now now casting all that to the side
i am hoping that it is going to be
goldie horn because she is of course
wyatt russell's real-life mother
she's won lots of awards and also with
kurt russell being in the mcu
it sort of brings the whole family in
together in the comics it was actually
walker's parents who were murdered
not battle star and this is the thing
that sent him off the deep end
so i was kind of thinking that they
might be doing this because of the meta
joke it creates
and also the fact that goldie horn has a
big personality
i also think she would work well with
thor and in my opinion it just takes a
number of boxes
however big let down here for you guys
since then i've dm'd and spoken to some
scoopers
and they've said they know the person
isn't blunt however
some have said that the person who
emailed me might be
simply of just linking up certain
appearances and assuming one is for
episode 5
when it could be for six the blonde
woman could easily be florence pew
who is rumored to be in the show however
this might be a separate cameo and not
the episode 5 one
we've already seen characters like
sharon carter rowdy and batroc turn up
from other things
so i'd guess that we might see more mcu
characters beyond just this episode 5
person
and florence pew being blonde it does
kind of fit into that
other guesses that i liked which people
sent in was charlize theron
and jennifer lawrence who at one point
was supposed to be playing sue storm
now a blunt woman might not turn up at
all either i'm just being transparent
with you guys
and i'm not someone who thinks i have
the most accurate sources in the world
which is
why i tend to do just standard
breakdowns oh we're doing pooper scoops
what should turn out to be john goodman
or someone now over to charles murphy
who has said that he's aware of the
actor and say that they aren't playing
the power broker
movie said that he's a big fan of them
but that everyone is way overdoing this
because of this don't expect to see
someone like wolverine or professor x
show up
as they're way too big for what this
cameo is now one thing that's kind of
annoying
is a number of people who know who it is
have hyped up this cameo but then
they've recently downplayed it
and told us not to speculate i think
this is purely because of one division
and all the backlash that came over it
when fan theories turned out to be
untrue
but i would say if you don't want people
to speculate then just don't bring it up
at all yeah
don't hype up cameos at all in general
as people
like myself will of course make guesses
and dig deep and try and find out who it
is
people in the comic book community are
clearly going to make guesses
so if you open the can of worms you
better be ready for the dirt that comes
with it
now i really hope that it's someone big
but they might drop another boner
and just have anthony mackie playing
smiling tiger or something
anyway that's everything we know you've
heard my guess with goldie horn
so i want to turn it over to you guys
and in the comments below
drop your best guess on who the
character could be of the clues we have
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you're going to be entered into a
prize during the 30th of april in which
we're giving away three copies of zack
snyder's justice league in 4k
the first person who gets the cameo
right before friday will
automatically win one so yeah best guess
is below
as you know you've got quite a good
chance here and the winners of last
month's competition are on screen right
now so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode four
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the entire thing from top
to bottom and pointed out the best
easter eggs in it
so definitely check it out if you want
to know more without the way thank you
for sticking through
the video i've been poor i'll see you
next time take care
peace